in this course Pete Lemaster will teach
you how to create a classic Android
style shooting game with pi game and
python completely from scratch p is a
control systems engineer and creator of
the Lemaster Tech YouTube channel
alright so let's do a quick project
showcase and give you a little
background and description of the
project before we dive into the tutorial
alright so some of the highlights of
this project are it's really a classic
arcade style feel with like scrolling
enemies of varying speeds and sizes that
give you progressively more points as
they get more difficult we created three
game modes where you can see how fast
you can clear the entire game in free
play mode and then in accuracy mode
where you have limited ammo to get as
many points as you possibly can and
lastly there's a timed mode to see how
many points you can get before your time
runs out you can also pause and resume
mid-run in any game mode or restart at
any time and then your high scoring is
tracked and saved in an external text
file that that you can reset from the
menu screen if you ever want to start
fresh the static images were all created
ahead of time using canva but you could
make your own versions using anything
from PowerPoint Google Slides canva
Photoshop any other software you like
you could even just download images from
the internet to customize yours I
included all code and assets including
images sound effects and music font and
text files that you would need for this
full build at the GitHub Link in the
description of the video as well the
basic steps that we do to build the game
are import and setup Pi game as well as
basic game variables and then import
some of our images then we draw the
static background images onto the game
then we draw our gun and have it rotate
based on Mouse position then we draw the
enemies into the game and then we
procedurally generate the enemy's
starting coordinates so we don't have to
give each enemy individual code and then
we make all of the enemies move with
Progressive difficulty based on what
tier enemy they are and then we check to
see if our Mouse click collides with
targets when we shoot and then we
advance between levels once we've killed
all the enemies on that screen and then
we draw the scoring and Status elements
onto the screen including total shots
taken how much time has elapsed how many
total points we've scored as well as a
status saying what mode we're in and
then we show how to navigate the main
menu screen the pause screen the game
over screen and all of the code that
comes with those buttons and then we
handle game over commands and conditions
as well as high score tracking including
reading and writing the high scores to
an external text file and then lastly we
take a look at adding some awesome
background music and sound effects to
the game all in all it takes just over
two hours to build from scratch it's
around 400 lines of code I had a ton of
fun building this I hope you do too so
without any further Ado let's get right
into the tutorial alright let's Dive
Right into this tutorial I'm sure I just
finished giving you guys a killer intro
so as always when you're building a pie
game game just start by in importing Pi
game you may need to run pip to install
it if you don't already have it
installed in your package and then we're
going to be doing some stuff with radial
geometry so using radians and degrees so
just import the math package right up
front as well and then go ahead and do
pygame dot init to sort of initialize
everything in the pi game package that
we'll be using in this game and let's
start just creating some setup variables
so go ahead and create an FPS or your
frame rate which will make 60 and then
create a timer using
pygame.time.clock and then let's go
ahead and just grab a font real quick so
any game where you're going to be
writing text which in our case we're
going to be saying like the score and
the time elapsed so we know we want font
go ahead and Define a font right up
front
and I'll just call it pygame.font dot
font and uh it so quick note if you
don't want to grab my full uh like
assets package from the GitHub you'll
need to create a lot of things you can
do every Graphics uh thing that I
created you can make your own in
PowerPoint or Google Slides or you can
just use like canva which is a nice
online design service I made all of mine
in canva Pro
I'm sure I talked about this in the
intro a little bit but essentially I did
a lot of the static text design ahead of
time so we didn't have to do every piece
of it in pygame
it's definitely possible to recreate
almost everything we're doing purely in
pi game but it's going to speed the
tutorial up a lot and make the game look
a lot smoother to kind of use a separate
application to design because pygame is
not exactly a design tool so you're
going to see a lot of these very
polished screens that are actually
screens have already made so I'm sure I
said something about that in the intro
of this video but just in case I didn't
there I covered my butt so if you want
to use like a free font and not go get
anything from the internet you can just
use freesands bold.ttf it comes
installed with almost any application
anytime you install your IDE you're
usually going to be able to find this
one now I actually went and grabbed an
ass uh font from online for free and I
put it in this font folder it's just
called my font.ttf so if you're
following along and you have a font that
you want to use or if you just want to
customize the font in your or game just
go ahead and point it to there but
actually this alone is not going to work
because we have it nested in a few
folders so we need to point to it which
is going to be assets forward slash font
and then forward slash my font just like
that
I know a lot of the people who've been
on this channel for a while have a lot
of familiarity with pi game fonts but I
like to assume there's beginners out
there every time as well so next thing
we're going to do is we're going to
create two constant variables for our
screen width and height and store them
in width and height and then right away
we're going to use those in screen
equals
pygame.display.set mode and then just in
square brackets give it a width and a
height we're going to be referring to
width and a height in this project quite
a lot so it's going to be nice to have
those in variables other than just like
having them hard coded and trying to
remember what we put for everything
and if you decide you want to mess with
the overall dimensions and make it a
different size you're just going to have
to scale a lot of the images that I
included in the GitHub okay
all right so now let's create some empty
holder lists for our backgrounds our
banners and um we'll uh just create
level equals zero and I think we have a
different colored gun for each level as
well yeah we do we have a different
colored gun for each level so we will
also create a list for guns here
and uh we're gonna create some for Loops
to automatically populate those you can
see in each folder
I gave each levels background banner and
gun just a numerical number so that we
can use a for Loop and just address it
to that number so let's go ahead and
take a look at how to do that
excuse me
all right so what we're going to say is
for I in range
and then we don't actually want it to
just be three so there's three levels
total in my version of the game you're
welcome to build it out more but we want
this for Loop to give us the values one
two and three so to do that we need to
say from one to four because uh python
for Loops are not end inclusive but they
are start inclusive so this is saying
for range starting at one going until
four but not including four so this for
Loop is gonna do uh an iteration where I
equals one two and then three
and for those three things we want to
append an image to all of our lists so
we're going to do uh pygame Dot
so bgs.append which is the command to
add an item to a python list and then
we're gonna do pygame dot image image
dot load and then that's the pi games
modules built-in commands to load an
image into your game and we're going to
make them formatted strings because we
need to use I in there so it's going to
be F and then assets forward slash BG's
forward slash and then in curly brackets
so that we can use a variable
do curly brackets I and then dot PNG so
this is going to go through and it's
going to grab backgrounds one two and
three without us needing three separate
lines of code
and you could say well we had to set up
a for Loop to do that so it's only
saving us one line of code right now but
we can do the exact same thing for guns
and Banners so it's going to be banners
dot append and then I'm going to copy
the rest of this because it's going to
be the same thing we just need to update
the uh Direction a little bit so instead
of BG's it's going to be banners and
then for guns dot append and I'm hoping
because this is all very arcade style
and very like fun uh kid-friendly like
not offensive that YouTube's not gonna
care about how many times you know we
say guns and shooting in this video
because it is not about actual violence
it is just about a fun little game but
you never know YouTube's got interesting
rules but I don't think they care about
the Master Tech too much
all right uh and so uh for now let's go
ahead and just leave it at that and um I
think that's probably good enough for
our initial startup here so let's just
uh go down to the main game Loop now so
that we can get the screen to kind of
start showing up and then we'll start
filling it in with more fun and useful
stuff so we'll say run equals true
and then while run okay and so this is
basically a quick and easy we create a
running variable that's a Boolean true
false and we say while it's true so
while run then the first thing we want
to do every Loop uh is going to be timer
dot tick at our frame rate our FPS and
then just really quickly to get the
screen kind of populating
we'll do screen dot fill and we'll just
make the background black as a default
and then probably the easiest thing to
do right after that is let's go ahead
and put the banner in the background of
whatever level we're in so we'll say
screen dot blit and then BG's and then
we're going to use one two and three as
the level but their indexes in our list
are zero one and two so we'll say level
minus one and then we're going to put
that in position zero zero so that's
saying we want our Banner our background
image that's this the actual like frame
for the the level we want that to be in
the top left corner for its starting
position and then we're going to do
basically the exact same command for
uh banners so we'll do banners but then
instead of zero zero it's going to be
zero and then for height we want height
minus 200. so I made my banners 200
pixels High
so that's where we want those to start
and now we're not going to see anything
unless we uh make this level variable a
1 instead of a zero because uh the way
I'm gonna have it uh work is if you're
in the menu or you're paused or you have
the game over screen up we're going to
treat that like level zero so all the
important game stuff like score and time
elapsed will be active only when level
is not equal to zero so for we are going
to start on level zero which will take
you to the main menu but for now let's
actually start on level one just so we
can see some stuff
and then right now this is what's called
an infinite while loop so uh there's
actually no way to exit this Loop and
that'll cause your com your game or your
computer to crash maybe both so we need
to just create a way to get out of the
infinite Loop so it'll be for event in
pygame dot event dot get just like this
and then we're going to say if event DOT
type is equal to and then pygame.quit
which is just this uh unique Pi game
command that's about the little red X
that's in the top right corner of your
window that button is just pygame.quit
and so if we get pygame.quit then we
want run to be equal to false and then
we just need to come outside of our for
Loop and do two commands the first one
is pygame dot display dot flip and then
outside of our while loop it's pygame
dot quit and this pygame.display.flip is
just essentially the command that says
take everything we've told you to draw
onto the screen and actually put it on
the screen and then pygame.quit is what
will actually close the program
so hopefully this already just these
lines of code that we've set up are
going to give us the background and
Banner for level one when we boot it up
and there you can go this is actually
pretty cool looking already in my
opinion I might be biased
um but I think that's pretty cool and if
you want to see all the levels all you
have to do is change what level we start
on initially to two and you'll see our
like Western theme and then three should
give us our like Space theme okay so
there we go that's pretty cool why don't
we take a look at um drawing the gun on
the screen so the like little arcade
style gun and we'll do that with a
function so let's come down into uh just
underneath where we BLT everything else
right now and let's say if the level is
greater than zero okay
so if level greater than zero then we'll
do this thing called draw a gun and then
we're going to come up in between our
variables and our uh main game Loop and
we'll create the function draw a gun I'm
not going to put any caps in it and I'm
going to spell it right it's a one-two
punch
all right and so the gun is basically
something I want to have almost like an
arcade gun it's like rotating about the
center roughly and it's just really more
for effect like the actual shooting is
going to be based on your mouse not
based on this gun this is purely for
style but I think it's really important
since we're making like a arcade style
game to do this step so what we're going
to do is we're going to say the mouse
position
is equal to pygame dot mouse dot get
pause and I happen to think this code
we're about to do is actually really
cool we're going to track where the
mouse is and we're going to rotate the
gun so that it's always looking at the
mouse and we're going to do it with
geometry which maybe you're a computer
scientist because you didn't like
geometry and math and you didn't want to
go into physics but I promise this is
not going to be uh too bad okay so the
point that we want the gun to
essentially pivot around will be the
middle of the screen and then kind of
right at the top of the banner because
if you think of yourself as like the
player of the game you're kind of
standing at the banner more or less and
shooting from there
that's how I see it so we're going to
put this point for the gun to Pivot
about right at width over two and then
uh height minus 200 is where we're going
to put that point okay and then we're
gonna
um when the mouse clicks we're gonna
just show a little dot where we clicked
so we're going to say lasers equals and
then we'll say uh we're gonna create a
little list here of what color we want
the different lasers for each level to
be so I'm going to say red purple and
then green and this is pure preference I
just think they look pretty cool and I
made my different like arcade guns for
each level I made red on the first level
purple on the second
and then green on the third
so I'm just gonna have little mouse
lasers that look the same
um okay and so now we're gonna store the
clicked status of the mouse in a list
that I'll call clicked clicks and that
command is pygame.mouse dot get pressed
and uh what's nice about this is it's
going to return a little list that tells
you the Left Right the left Mouse button
the scroll wheel click and the right
Mouse button in a little list called
clicks and so what we'll say is if the
mouse position 0 is not equal to
the gun point zero and this is actually
a really important step because we are
going to calculate the slope and so
slope if you're not familiar is rise
over run which means Y2 minus y1 over X2
minus X1 that's basic geometry and you
don't really actually need to know the
theory behind it just to follow along
but what's important about that is
because it's rise over run if you ever
had a situation where your mouse was
exactly in the middle of the screen as
well your run becomes zero it becomes X2
minus X1 but they're the same variable
and so you get a value of 0 and then
it's divided by zero computers don't
like dividing by zero so in just like on
paper you would write down Infinity for
the slope but the computer can process
that so basically this is just to cover
our butts that's maybe longer than I
should have talked about that but I
think it's important to explain where
I'm coming from
all right so as long as that is not the
case then we're going to calculate the
slope which is going to be uh Mouse
position one gun Point position one and
then divided by Mouse position zero
minus gun point zero okay and so this is
calculating the slope of a line if you
were to draw it between where we're
going to be rotating our gun about and
where our Mouse currently is
and we'll say else because we're going
to use the slope for math so if we are
in a situation where our Mouse is
exactly in the middle of the screen then
we'll do what we would we'll say else
and then slope is equal to
um just a really big negative integer
because basically that's gonna just give
us a line that's more or less straight
up this is as close to Infinity as we
have to get for our game if you don't
like that you can play around with that
and kind of see what happens as you
change that it's not the most important
part of the project so I'm not going to
spend too long on it all right now we're
going to get the angle that that slope
correlates with and to do that we're
going to use math and then the inverse
tan or a tan command
which again basic geometry inverse
tangent of a slope of a line will tell
you the angle between like the
horizontal axis and that line
but again geometry is kind of boring
when you're building games so we're
going to move on pretty quickly from
that you just take my word for it and
then to get the actual rotation that we
want we're going to use math again and
we're going to convert our degrees or
our angle into degrees because angle is
being read in at radians and the pi game
dot transform dot rotate command we're
about to use needs it in degrees instead
of
needs in degrees instead of radians
okay so now let's go ahead and take a
look we're going to do two different
things based on the mouse position
so if we look at one of these guns real
quick we'll see that the right half of
the rotation as I'm looking at my screen
the right half of the rotation
will look pretty good if it's like this
but it would actually look better if
this was flipped horizontally when we're
on the left half of the screen rather
than like awkwardly bending all the way
backwards to shoot it'll look more like
you just rotated your shoulders or
something so let's go ahead and take a
look at the mouse X position so we'll
say if Mouse pause zero is greater than
we'll start with less than width over
two okay so this means that the X
position of our Mouse is on the left
side of the screen then we'll say gun is
equal to pygame dot
transform transform dot flip and then we
just have to tell it what image we're
flipping and so it's going to be guns
and then again it's going to be level
minus one because levels will be one two
and three but the indexes in the lists
will be zero one and two that's just how
indexes work in lists so don't come at
me
all right and then we just give it uh
true and then false because this is do
we want to flip it in the X Direction
which yes that's the direction we want
flip it in and then this second one is y
direction and we don't want to flip it
in the y direction okay
and now uh what we'll say is
if
uh
uh no that's just that's just defining
the gun now we will say
um
if Mouse position
y 1 is less than and then we'll do 600.
so uh think about our window the first
600 are the shooting gallery and then
the bottom 200 are the menu and we don't
want to be shooting when we're in the
menu we want to be like selecting the
pause button or the restart button or
we're just looking at our score whatever
so we only want to actually draw the gun
on the screen if our Mouse is in the
like shooting gallery area Okay so if
the mouse y position is in that first
600 of the screen then we will do screen
dot blit and then rather than just
blitting the gun we need to transform
the gun image so pygame.transform dot
rotate
and then it's going to be the gun
and then here's where maybe my the way I
format my guns in hindsight might not
have been perfect but there's a really
easy fix for it I have the guns pointing
straight up initially and if they were
pointing horizontally it would just go
where we told it but so basically we're
off by 90 degrees from what like a
logical rotation might be so we just
needed to say 90 minus that rotation and
as soon as we boot this up you'll see
why we need to do that and again feel
free to mess with that angle and see
what happens if you don't
okay and so uh then we need to give it
an X and Y position to blit onto
um and it's going to be width over to
minus 90. Because the actual image of
the gun has a lot of dead space to the
left and to the right uh so it's going
to be width over to minus 90 just to
scoot it more to the middle of the
screen and then it's going to be height
minus 250 because we don't want to sit
right at 200 otherwise the whole gun
would be down in like the score section
and that wouldn't look uh that would
look kind of weird
so this is just going to move it where
we actually want it okay all right so
let's go ahead and say if clicks zero
then let's also go ahead and pygame.draw
Dot Circle let's go ahead and draw on
the screen
a little color to indicate that we can
detect that we've clicked and this is
going to be really useful once we get to
the point where we're actually checking
to see if we've shot enemies then this
will be really useful so we're gonna add
the mouse position we're just going to
draw a little circle the color of our
gun whatever our laser for the level is
and we'll make it radius five
and so now we just need to say else
right so we checked what to do if the
mouse position is on the left half of
the screen so now we'll say else
and if else it's a little bit easier
then the gun just becomes equal to guns
at level minus one we don't have to flip
it because it's already oriented this
way
and then
we're going to say if so now we can kind
of take these three four lines and we
can copy them down because this is very
similar
um it's still if the mouse is less than
600 but now instead of 90 minus rotation
it's actually 270 minus rotation which
should make sense to you guys we flipped
it 180 so we need to add that 180 on to
our correction factor
um but then with over two and this time
it's minus 30 uh again feel free to boot
this up I'm trying to save you a little
time in the interim and I know how long
my tutorials can get
um but feel free to play around with
this if you want this is just
essentially a correction factor so the
guns actually sit in about the middle
and about the same position okay
uh and that should be all we need to do
if we boot this up I don't think yeah I
left on level three so we should get the
green gun and you can see right away
it's huge and that's because I made very
large
um gun images because it's typically
it's easier to take something make it
detail that large scale and then
compress it down so that it's a little
bit smaller and to fix that it's a
really easy command it's just
pygame.transform just like we did for
rotate but this time it's scale
and then so first thing you give it is
the image which is pretty easy it's this
image we're loading in and then you just
give it another argument which is what
you want to scale it down to and so my
original images were 500 500 so to keep
overall dimensions correct to keep
overall scale correct we're going to
scale it down to 100 100
and that right there is going to fix it
for all three of our guns or it should
yeah so now you can see we get this cool
little rotating gun and I mean again I
get geeked out over some of this stuff
but I think that's a really cool bit of
programming if our Mouse is down in the
menu the gun goes away because it knows
we're not trying to shoot we're maybe
selecting a menu button but as soon as
we're back in the gallery we have this
gun that's rotating and if you think of
yourself as like the game player that's
pretty much where you'd be standing and
you can see when we click we get this
little red like pew pew like Star Wars
laser
uh free sound effects for you guys and
uh let's go ahead and take a look it
should be read on level one if
everything's working properly yeah so
that right there that looks pretty good
um so we are going to go ahead and move
on having a little trouble here
we're gonna go ahead and move on and uh
we got that really satisfying game
mechanic down but I think we should uh
probably next take a look at drawing a
level onto the screen
um and by draw level I sort of mean draw
the targets of a level
so to do that we are going to want to
load in all of our targets and in here
you can see I have uh birds for level
one again these are not real birds no
animal violence is intended
um but I just feel like I get the
disclaimer out but we have uh plates for
two because I don't know there's
something about like an old-timey
Western like plate shooting gallery and
then for three we're gonna shoot
spaceships
so let's go ahead and load our Targets
in and uh to do that we are gonna want
to create a list similar to what we did
for uh BG's and Banners and guns and now
we're just gonna make a list called
Target images
Target
images and a niche this is actually we
want this to be a list of lists so we
want a list of each image
for each level so we have three levels
right so we're gonna put three items in
here but then each of them should be a
list of the three images for that level
hopefully that didn't get too confusing
and then one more thing I'm going to do
is actually create a dictionary to look
up how many of each uh like tier of
enemy to put in each level
so in level one I'm gonna have ten of
the biggest or level one enemies and
then I'm gonna have five of the
intermediate ones and then three of the
smallest ones and then in two I'm just
going to increase the total number of
enemies by a bit so we'll do twelve
eight five
and then just because I wanted to be
difficult uh because life isn't hard
enough already we're gonna do three of
the uh we're gonna do a lot of
spaceships on the third level and we're
actually gonna add in a fourth tier
we're gonna add in this purple spaceship
just for the level three it's gonna be
real small really high up on the screen
and moving really fast it's kind of like
a you know Boss Challenge right before
you beat the game it just adds some
difficulty
and so we're going to use this targets
and Target images uh inside this for
Loop that we're already using uh to
populate those lists okay
excuse me
all right so first thing is let's handle
what to do on levels one or two so if I
is less than three then we're going to
say for J in range and we're going to go
from one to four again so that we use
one two and three then we're going to
say Target images and this time it's not
just Target images.append it's Target
images at I minus one so that'll give us
again I is going to be one or two we
want to write the images for level one
into index zero so Target images I minus
one dot append and then in here it's
something you should have already been
familiar with because we did it right
here
um
it's going to be this
pygame.image.load with a transform as
well I'm going to put on two lines for
you guys just so it's a little easier to
see here
um but it's going to be we're going to
scale these guys and we're going to load
them now from uh assets and then forward
slash targets and then this is kind of
tricky but you guys are going to handle
it no problem we need to pull the image
from I and then J so I is telling us
what level we're looking at the targets
for and then J is telling us which
actual one to add
and that's why we have to separate it
out between I is less than three and I
is equal to 3 because in I is equal to 3
this has to be one to five so that we
catch that purple spaceship as well
and then it wouldn't be super fun or
entertaining if they were all exactly
the same size
but it would also take me a long time to
go through and manually give them each a
size and so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to say well you're all going to be
equal to 120 minus and then to make it
kind of progressively more difficult I'm
going to make them smaller based on what
level they are so when J is 1 we're
going to bring the first ones down to
102 basically 102 by and then this will
do 80 minus J times 12. so it's
basically the first one will be 102 and
then the second and then the y direction
it'll be of 68 tall but then the second
ones will be 18 by 12 smaller than that
and the third ones will be 36 by 24
smaller than that so this is a fun way
of without a ton of work creating
progressively smaller
enemies as they uh as we go through and
iterate through the list okay so
probably that confused some of you guys
um but just drop me a drop me a comment
if you got turned around there
um okay and now let's look at the else
conditions and I'm actually going to
copy all this because it's not that
different
um it's just else we need to say for J
in range uh one through five and I'm
sure there's a clever way you could
basically say like this is gonna be I
floor divided by three
um plus four or something and just do
this all in one Loop but uh I don't feel
like spending the time to think through
this and this is already pretty
efficient here so uh great this is going
to give us all of the images loaded in
for all of our enemies
so now if we go ahead and you're gonna
see me collapsing a lot of the functions
while we're not working on them that's
just to keep the code a little cleaner a
little easier for me to move through
because obviously 400 lines of code
we're jumping all over the place so that
that's what that is but again any
questions at any point just let me know
in the comments below and now let's take
a look at what to do when we're drawing
a level so we'll say Define
draw the level so this is going to be
drawing all of the enemies for the level
that we're currently in and so we'll say
if level is equal to one or level is
equal to two
uh and this this uh Target Rex is going
to be essentially the enemy hitboxes so
as we're going through and we're drawing
the enemies onto the screen we're also
going to create hitboxes
um because pygame doesn't know where
images are necessarily per se it just
starts by drawing them in a certain spot
but you have Dead Space they're
obviously not perfect rectangles unless
you're building kind of like a boring
game
um no shade at anyone who's making an
all squares Shooting Gallery but so
we're going to create hitboxes basically
inside of the images they're just going
to be invisible rectangles that we'll
use for Collision detection later and
for levels one or two we want this to
initially start out empty
and then for level three we just need to
add a fourth tier in there for this
empty so that we have somewhere to place
it
quick water break
all right now we're gonna have to get a
list of coordinates to where we want to
draw these things from and we'll do that
initializing
um right after we take a look at what to
do them
do with them so let's just assume that
we've passed in a list of the
coordinates of all the enemies well it's
going to be for I in range range length
of coordinates so there there we're
going to be taking the that's an in not
a second I so now we're going to be
taking a look at each individual thing
in our coordinates and then we'll say 4J
in range and then length of chords I
because coordinates is most likely going
to be a list of lists
then what we want to do is say Target
Rex
dot at I dot append and we're going to
put in a little rectangle that's going
to say the hitbox of each thing and so
pygame.rect.rect and it's going to be
chords at i j so that's what level and
then that's what individual
um enemy and so I will say we're gonna
do some stuff here that is the right way
to do it but maybe it would have made
more sense if we'd initialize the
coordinates first we're in a little too
deep now but I promise we're gonna show
how we initialize the coordinates right
after this and then I'll come back and
review this if I remember
but so the X and Y starting position for
these coordinates for the hitbox
are basically going to be the x
coordinate and then the y-coordinate so
chords
I whoop I and then J and then because
each coordinate pair is an X and then a
y coordinate in a tuple you have to say
well this is the x coordinate this is
the y coordinate
and I'll tell you right off the bat that
the images are also a little too big for
us to use the exact starting X position
they're all they all have dead space on
the sides
so 20 pixels makes a really accurate
more fair game
um if you were to if you were to make
that uh much smaller like a plus five
you would just get a much wider hitbox
or it would start kind of off to the
left and not make a ton of sense
all right so the four things we need to
give a rectangle when we're defining it
our X and Y starting position and then
width and height and for width and
height we're going to make it based off
of
um we're going to make it based off of
what uh level they're on
so it's going to be 60 minus I times 12
and then comma
60 minus
minus I times 12. and so this will make
them progressively smaller as we go up
in difficulty tiers
okay
rename the element oh just because I
have a for Loop in the outside world
and again you may be saying wait I
thought J was what tier of enemy they
were well that's not exactly right these
are coordinates just for whatever level
we're on
um okay so all right we got to get
through this one so that I can show you
what the actual coordinates list is
going to look like so screen dot BLT and
this is where we're actually going to
draw the images onto the screen so
Target images
level -1 and then the coordinates are
just going to be level minus one and
then I
we're still inside the for Loop and we
still need to draw the Right image so
it's whatever level we're on from our
Target images and then I which says what
tier they are
and then the actual coordinate pair so I
and then J and so this is going to draw
our image in the coordinates that we
give and then we're going to return a
list of all of the rectangle hitboxes
for those okay so oop just Target Rex
not targets all right so I know I
probably confused a few of you guys I
briefly confused myself there we need to
talk about initializing these
coordinates so let's come right before
the for the while loop we don't want to
do this every single iteration of the
loop because we really just need to
generate the starting positions of all
our enemies and then we'll move them
throughout the game but we don't want to
re-initialize the positions
okay so let's just say that uh let's
initialize
enemy enemy coordinates and then after
we do this we'll go back up into our
draw level and we'll talk about it a
little bit more all right so
initializing the enemy coordinates let's
start with a list of all the coordinates
that'll be empty so for uh one we'll do
one not ones coordinates it's going to
be a list of lists right so we'll have
the coordinates for our tier one enemies
our tier two enemies and our tier three
enemies and then
we'll just make these lists right here
for one two and three and as always we
just have that one extra tier of enemy
in level three so we need that fourth
empty bracket
all right and now
uh I don't know why it's reformatting my
stuff okay and so now what we're gonna
say is for I
in range and then three
let's go back yep for I in range three
we'll say
my list is equal to targets that
dictionary we made at uh at Key one
right so the value this is going to
create a little list that is just the
list in targets one so we're saying look
at the key inside of our targets
dictionary for key one and then take
that value which is ten five three
and store that in this little list which
is my list and uh so we'll say targets
one and then we'll say 4J in range range
my list
I okay so this is saying
um now for each item inside of my list
uh and so remember my list at I for 0 1
and 2 is now going to be numerical
values which for level one is ten five
and three so this is saying for J in
range and then our for our first Loop
where I is equal to zero it's going to
say for J in range 10.
so it's creating 10 coordinate pairs for
us and it's going to say one coordinates
chords
we'll say towards is okay
we're going to say one chords at I
dot append because again we need to say
well right now we're doing this tier
list and then this tier list and then
this tier list of coordinates so one
chords I dot append and then we need to
give it in here the coordinates where we
want each enemy to be drawn and just to
make it really easy and kind of
procedurally drawn we're going to say
the starting X position
will just be a function of the total
number of objects in that tier of enemy
so for example if there are 10 and we
have a 900 wide screen each enemy is
going to be spaced apart horizontally by
90 pixels okay so we're going to start
by saying append and then width let me
get my parentheses correct here we've
got width floor divided by which floor
division just gives you
um essentially a round down to the
closest Whole integer and then times J
so times whatever this is if this is our
zeroth if this is our first uh picture
it'll draw it at 90 if it's our second
it'll draw it at 180 etc etc and uh then
for our y coordinate we'll make it uh
300 minus
and then I times 150 and then just to
move them up and down a little I didn't
put a minus in there we go
so this is basically saying our first
Loop we want to draw these suckers 300
down from the top of the screen our
second tier we'll put at like 150 down
and we'll draw our top tier right at the
top of the screen where the images start
at zero pixels from the top okay and now
we'll space them up and down every other
just to be kind of fun so we'll move
them vertically by 30 times and then
this is J modulo 2 is essentially uh J
remainder two so this is saying every
other we're going to have an odd number
for J which means the remainder will be
1 which means that uh that mean that
means that this will be just adding 30
to its y position so this little bit of
code is really just a simple
straightforward way to get like every
other patterns in drawings
all right and now we just need to do the
exact same thing for uh two chords
except
well really except nothing except the
text needs to change to two
um but again I felt it was a little bit
easier to do it with separate for Loops
just because uh the third one is a
little bit different so now it's for I
in range four and also this needs to be
targets two and this needs to be targets
three
and then because this one has four tiers
rather than moving them uh up by 150
each time we want to buy a hundred each
time and trust me when we get to the
spaceship levels that's going to be a
lot of enemies but it's still gonna look
really good
okay and so I believe that's all we need
to do to generate the
coordinate system let me re go through
that one more time just because I know
there's probably a lot of confused
viewers trying to follow along and
saying what the heck did you just do
here and if you didn't good for you
you're really smart
um
but so basically we're saying we want to
quickly get a coordinate for every enemy
we defined in our dictionary so right we
said at level one we want Ted ten big
red birds five medium-sized bluebirds
and then three little green birds and
then twelve eight and five for the
plates and then for the UFOs we're gonna
have 15 red UFOs we're gonna have 12
blue ones eight green ones and three
little purple ones zipping around the
screen and the way we set this up as
you're playing with your game you can
mess around with these numbers and
figure out what you actually think like
a fair number of enemies for each level
is just by changing them here and we set
it up to be procedural and smart so that
it'll just be easily adjustable and
it'll just expand and and kind of
contract with changing those numbers
but so basically right when the game
boots up uh and not inside the loop
we're gonna generate some coordinates
and we're gonna create these empty lists
to store the coordinates in and so for
level one this first empty block is
going to store all the Red Birds
coordinates this second block is going
to store all the blue ones and the third
wall store or the green ones
that's what I is here are you the big
red bird the medium-sized Bluebird or
the little green bird okay and then
we're grabbing a temporary list just
called my list
from the target's dictionary based on
what level coordinates we're generating
it so in targets we said level one is
going to be this list of how many
enemies to have and we store that in my
list
then we create this second for Loop
which is for J in range my list I so
that's saying for however many of the
bird that I'm currently looking at the
tier that I'm currently looking at so
for big red bird this is 10. so for J in
range 10 and then I want to just create
an x and y coordinate based on what tier
of enemy I am where the harder smaller
tier goes higher and higher up on the
screen
and then the uh the
um larger birds are also going to be uh
lower on the screen and then the number
of uh enemies is going to determine your
Exposition on the screen
so that's what we did so now we're gonna
have three coordinates list one chords
two chords and three chords that are a
list of lists or an array
where each
each list inside there is a specific
tiers set of coordinates so if we look
at draw level again then we're saying
for I in range length of chords which is
telling us how many tiers of enemy do I
have okay and so for one and two that's
going to say three basically because the
length of chords list for level one and
level two
are going to be three items and then for
level three this will be a four but then
we say for J in range length of coward's
I so this is saying for however many
enemies of that tier there are
then I want to create a hitbox based on
what tier of enemy it is which is I
um that'll get progressively smaller as
the enemies get smaller and then I want
to draw the image for that enemy onto
the screen at its coordinate system okay
so super complicated I guess but I think
you'll see exactly what we just did if
we go ahead and boot this up
should see a bunch of well list index
out of range okay so let's go ahead and
take a look at line 87 of our code here
and see what's going on oh it's just
that we forgot to change this to three
chords so when it got to uh essentially
I equals four there was nowhere to store
that I equals three there was nowhere to
store that so just be careful when you
copy paste to make sure you catch all
your copy paste mistakes
um and I do not always do that okay and
so our Birds is not on the screen and I
was about to panic that our draw level
function didn't work but you guys
probably uh caught this we didn't put
draw level on the screen anywhere so
draw a level and then the coordinates
that we want to pass in are just going
to be uh one chords if
level is equal to one then we're going
to pass in one chords and uh we are
going to just do some L ifs based on
what level we're on so L if level is two
then pass in two chords and then L if
level is three pass in three chords
three chords there we go and then two
chords
okay so this should give us uh all of
our Birds
no okay
argument must be wrecked style object so
I guarantee this is just me uh not using
the right formatting not uh properly
copying something to the second line so
let's look here
so
pygame.rec.rec there needs to be one
more parenthesis level in here so just
double check dot append that should be
the back one and then dot rect should be
yeah so we need one more level of core
uh there we go so inside
pygame.rec.rec there needs to be two
sets of tuples X and Y start position
and then
um width and height and I just got the
parentheses messed up so let's try that
one more time there's a bunch of bunch
of birds but they are not uh they're not
spaced out appropriately so let's go
ahead and take a look at our initialized
chords one more time just to see what
we're doing wrong oh I see it right away
these are supposed to be I times 150s
not minus 150s and minus 100s uh it's
hard it's hard to it's hard to teach and
do at the same time but let's take a
look that should fix it
there you go and you can see this uh
it's really cool it's a cool spacing
let's go ahead and change the levels to
two and three just to kind of see where
everybody starts so this is where our
plates will start and then let's look at
where our UFOs will start
and there should be a lot yeah you can
see we've got now we've got that fourth
tier even which is really cool so
shooting them doesn't do anything yet
and also we don't
um we don't have any way of like moving
between levels when you've shot all of
your enemies uh so let's go ahead and
also when we draw the level right we get
Target rectangles back so let's go ahead
and say
um where is draw levels here they are so
these should all return
um
Target
let's say boxes so we don't get confused
with what Target rectangles is
okay so let's go ahead and say Target
boxes Target boxes is equal to those so
now we're actually getting that back and
let's go ahead and take I think the next
best thing to do is just going to be
take a look at how to make those guys
move across the screen because then it
really starts feeling like a game it
starts looking like an arcade game and
to do that just like we made this draw
level uh function we're gonna make a
move level function okay
so we will say
move level and we'll give it the
coordinates as well and so choo choo
draw level move level draw level move
level and I know you guys are like Pete
don't forget the copy paste errors
because I keep having those
but I caught him this time you guys I
caught him
all right so let's go up above draw
level just because that's where I want
to put it and let's define move level
all right and there's a lot of different
ways you could make these guys move you
could make them uh wiggle up and down as
they go across the screen I'm just going
to make it to where they all move
laterally across the screen
and I'm just going to make the higher
smaller targets move a little faster so
increasing levels of difficulty that's
pretty much how those arcade games work
but there are definitely ways you can
Spruce this up just based on your own
creativity
all right so let's say if level is equal
to one or level is equal to two then
we'll say
that our maximum value is three right so
we need some variable that says how big
our for Loop should be if we only want
to do this once
and then we'll say else
Max vowel is equal to four and now let's
set up a for Loop that'll move
everything based on what tier of enemy
it is so we'll say 4 I in range
Max Val that variable we just came up
with we'll say 4J in range
length of coords
at I there we go so this again I know
how many tiers of like parentheses and
everything and nested for Loops were
passing through but try to keep it
straight that we're passing in one
level's worth of coordinates and each
coordinates list is an array where each
item inside of that is another list of
all of the coordinates for that item so
basically we're saying for J in range
length of coordinates I which is saying
for as many enemies of the tier that I'm
currently looking at and then what we'll
say is we'll move the coordinates of the
object that we're looking at into a
temporary uh Tuple because you cannot
adjust values in a tuple it's just the
nature of python tuples which is
parentheses with two values in them you
can't overwrite those so if we're trying
to move them if we're trying to move
every enemy at the same time
we can't just overwrite the uh
individual items in a tuple we have to
actually change just what the entire
Tuple is
so we'll move the previous coordinates
into this variable my chords and we'll
say if my so let's start by handling
like passing off screen to the left
we'll say if my chords zero so the X
position is less than negative 100 is
less than negative 150 which will let
even the biggest uh Target get fully off
screen
then we say coords at i j is equal to
and we move it all the way to the right
Edge now so we'll have everything
scrolling to the left just to be easy
and then we'll say the coordinates i j
are equal to width and then we'll leave
the y position as is so that's uh my
chords one
and this is a tuple because it's
coordinates
okay so this is basically saying if I've
gone off screen to the left I'm just
going to move you over to the right so
you basically are permanently cycling
until you get shot
and then we'll say else meaning you're
still on screen in some form or fashion
we'll say chords at IJ are equal to and
now a new Tuple which is going to be our
X position
minus and we'll say 2 to the power of
whatever tier of enemy we are okay so if
this is uh tier zero which um I guess is
the big red birds then this is going to
be 2 to the zero which is one so the red
enemies are going to move left at a
speed of one but then if you're a tier
uh one this becomes two to the first
Power which is minus two so it just
doubles the speed but what's really fun
is if you're a tier three enemy so
you're the little green bird in the
first level
this is 2 squared or minus 4 and then it
gets it's minus 8 with the little purple
UFOs so you'll see once we get to level
three this is actually going to make the
purple guys really fast and pretty hard
to hit okay and then we'll leave the Y
coordinates alone all right so this is
saying if you're on screen
I'm going to move you to the left based
on what tier of enemy you are and then
we're just gonna return the coordinates
back since we're overwriting them so we
need to come down to where we have move
level and we just need to understand
that we're getting one chords back from
uh this and we're getting two chords
back from this and we're getting
three
coords back from this okay so this is
gonna give us
um
this is going to update all of our
coordinates uh should for everything
simultaneously we still have level three
in here let's go ahead and boot up and
hopefully we have a bunch of nope I
messed something up but no surprise
there uh okay so let's take a look line
70 it says that else chords i j are
equal to and then my chords ah this
needs to be the x coordinate so it needs
to be my chords at zero minus two to the
I silly mistake but let's try that again
hopefully we get a bunch of UFOs moving
yeah so here you go all right so this is
really cool right does this not already
give you like retro arcade shooter game
feel
um and you can see these purple uh these
purple UFOs are absolutely yielding
across the screen they are just flying
um and even the blue ones and the green
ones are moving pretty good I think I've
continually been saying that like blue
was before green I don't know if that's
how I did it for every level but it
looks like let's see what two is so
where are the blue plates yeah okay so
on level one and two I made blue
um the middle lever level level but let
me see I guess that's so funny okay so
the the second tier on the third level
is green the second tier on level one
and two are blue uh hopefully I don't
have a bunch of OCD uh viewers out there
who feel the need to flip that but if
you uh do feel the need to flip that I'm
sure you can figure it out
alrighty so I think probably the best
thing to do next would be
um let's figure out how to check the
shot so check if uh if our Mouse clicks
let's check and see if we have hit a
Target and if we have let's go ahead and
give some points so let's introduce like
the uh format of scoring here so we'll
say
um down below level we'll just say
points is equal to zero initially we'll
create a new variable to track our
points
and uh we're just going to create a
variable that I think we'll call Define
check shot so we're checking when we've
shot
and what we're going to need to pass in
here is the list of our targets and the
coordinates of um and the coordinate
list and the reason we need both is
because we are checking to see if the
rectangular hitboxes that are stored in
our Target List have been hit but if it
has been hit then we need to delete out
the coordinates for that uh enemy
because that's how we actually track how
many enemies are left not this targets
list this coordinates list right if you
think of draw level and move level
they're based on how many sets of
coordinates we have not how many
rectangles there are in the targets list
so we know right off the bat that what
we're doing is if we've shot something
we need to return a modified coordinate
list that says that one is no longer in
there okay
and we'll just call the global of points
because it's easier to modify in here if
we just say Global points um but you you
could pass it in and return it as a
parameter as well and now I'm going to
get the mouse position kind of just like
we already did in the draw level and I'm
going to say
pygame.mouse.getpause and I'm going to
say for I in range length of
targets which will be our list of all of
the target's hitboxes and each thing in
there is going to be a
rectangle yeah okay for Iron Range
length of targets so targets again is a
list of lists it's another one of those
arrays thinking back to let me go where
did we create that that was draw level
right yeah so this target rects is what
we're calling the targets list in here I
just always try to call it something a
little different when we use them inside
functions so we don't get our wires
crossed
but this is the target Rex list and it's
this list of lists so we're gonna do
another nested for Loop which is for I
and range length of targets and then for
J in range length of targets I and
you're probably getting sick of watching
me type nested for Loops but
they do a lot of work for us
okay
and now what we're going to say is if
targets
i j
dot Collide point with the mouse
position
then we want coords at I so now we're
saying
I which is going to be whatever tier of
Target we're looking for so chords I
dot pop and then J and pop is the python
command for popping a specific item out
of a python list using the index of that
item so we have I which tells us what
tier of targeted is and then J which
tells us tells us its place in the
chords and targets list and so we just
want to pop that set of coordinates out
of our coordinates list
and then what we're going to do as well
is we're going to add so plus equals two
points we're going to do 10 plus and
then this is sort of similar to how we
place them and size them we're going to
make it Progressive based on uh the tier
of the enemy so we're going to say 10
plus 10 raised uh 10 times I to the not
two yeah I squared okay so this let's
think through what this means for the
different tiers okay this is 10 plus 10
times 0 squared for uh red enemies which
just means zero so this is going to be
red enemies are worth 10 points now for
the second level of enemy that which is
going to be
I equals one this is I squared which is
just one and then times 10. so this
makes the lowest rung of enemy worth 10
the second rung worth 20 but then the
third rung this becomes 2 squared so 4
times 10 which is 40 plus 10. so our
enemy Point values go 10 20 50. now try
to do the math what happens if we have
those purple UFOs what does that do to
score this is 3 squared which is 9 so 9
times 10 is 90. so that that makes them
worth a hundred so the tier scores are
10 20 50 and 100 just by this one simple
line of code checking what tier of enemy
we just shot
all right and now we gotta do
um this is where we'll come back and
I'll leave ourselves a note so add
sounds for
enemy hit when we get to sounds at the
end we're gonna put the sounds right in
here where we're hitting them but that's
all we have to do right now for the
inside of the check shots function the
only other thing we have to do is we
have to figure out where the right place
to call that is actually going to be and
so what we need to do is we need to
create a variable that's checking to see
if we've shot or not so we'll create a
variable we'll say shot equals false
and then I'm going to come down inside
of each of these if levels and I'm going
to say okay if shot then we want to
check and see that one chords is equal
to and then uh check shot and then the
target list so we called it Target boxes
in the outside world and then one chords
okay and we're gonna copy this same bad
boy
into each of these guys so if shot then
two coords target box and we pass in the
list for two chords and then you guessed
it we're doing the same thing for three
three chords and then Target boxes and
then three chords and now we need to
figure out what should trigger the shot
variable because uh everything else in
here should work on its own other than
one thing I always forget if you make
this if shot statement and you only want
to run once which we do right once per
click then you want to make sure that
shot equals false once you've executed
the code so this is saying once we
figured out how to check whether or not
we shoot which will be based on a mouse
click then we want to run this check
shot once depending on what level we're
on and then we want to immediately say
okay well I'm not checking that anymore
so shot is equal to false this will
prevent you from being able to hold down
the mouse click and just drag it all
over the screen because that would not
be very fun if you just had some kind of
like infinite ray gun that couldn't be
stopped
or maybe you guys think that would be
super fun
but that's not how I'm gonna make mine
okay so let's come down underneath our
if event DOT type is pygame.quit and
let's add a new event type so this will
be if event DOT type is equal to and now
it's going to be Pi game dot mouse
button down and it's all caps because
it's crazy
and I'm going to say event dot button is
equal to one so similar to the mouse get
clicked function that we already uh have
looked at the mouse clicks get clicked
um that we use to draw the where was
that that was in draw a level right
yeah so the um not draw level where come
on guys help me out draw a gun
thanks for the help uh so this if clicks
this is saying um
you know get all of the clicks from the
uh
pygame.mouse.getpressed now pygame.mouse
get uh
pygame.mouse.event dot button this one
that we're using in event handling is a
little bit different because the left
key is one uh for event right here
um but it in get clicked that other
thing we were looking at it's zero so
just understand this is still me saying
if the mouse button has been pressed and
it's the left click because I'm not
going to let you shoot with the right
click I guess you could if you wanted to
um
but uh anyways this is saying if you
click the mouse and it's the left button
I'm gonna again I'm gonna get the mouse
position
um out here because that's important for
knowing what we've clicked on so Mouse
position equals
pygame.mouse dot get pause just like
before and then let's go ahead and say
if and now uh if my mouse position X so
Mouse position X and remember this is
sort of like when we checked to whether
or not to draw the gun okay we want to
check whether the mouse position is on
the screen so this is zero to width
because if your mouse is off of the
little window that you're playing on
you're doing something else on your
computer so we shouldn't be messing with
the game okay and then we want to say
and
the Y position so Mouse position Y and
this uh this putting it in between two
kind of less than brackets is just our
way of putting it in a range in just one
command it cuts down on the total number
of and statements we need by a lot
all right so now the Y position
the Y position for this one just needs
to be uh less so greater than zero still
meaning in the window and then height
minus 200 is basically
um is basically the shooting window
right that's where our enemies could be
and so if that's all true then we'll set
shot equal to true
uh and then when we're tracking uh total
shots and ammunition so like we'll do an
accuracy mode where you only get a
certain number of bullets to get the
highest score you possibly can
so we'll do two other things anytime we
shoot we'll add one to a total shot
tracker and then we'll just say if mode
is equal to one so that'll be our
accuracy mode we'll do ammo minus equals
one
and it's just smart to Think Through
is there additional game functionality
that I'd want to put in here while I'm
doing it and so in this case I think
there is but we need to make these
variables so we'll say
mode and initially will set equal to
zero but just to kind of give you what
I'm thinking I'm thinking zero will be
the free play mode one will be accuracy
and then two will be timed for mode and
then ammo initially will make it zero
because if you're playing free play
you're gonna have infinite ammo it will
only check ammo if mode is one and then
we'll set total shots equal to zero when
the game boots up because you haven't
taken any shots we're not going to mess
with modes just yet first we're gonna
keep working on just how to check if
something's been shot and get it off the
screen
um but it's important to have those in
there so what should happen now if we
did everything right and that's a big if
I'll admit
um but if we did everything right then
that should give us everything we need
to yeah remove plates okay so that's
really cool we can just shoot the plates
off of the screen with our Mouse clicks
and it's very satisfying it really is
it's not the most difficult thing in the
world but that's where you guys as
programmers can come in and uh add your
own challenges to it so that was level
two let's go ahead and take a look at
what level three is going to look like
level three because that's got the
little UFOs on it okay yeah and those
UFOs are booking it
um I actually like do find myself
missing the purple uh UFOs pretty often
obviously you just have this red uh wave
it's gonna be a lot of Americans
triggered by that sentence
um
but you just have all these red UFOs
right across the bottom but so it's
really fun but you may have noticed
there there's nothing when you clear a
level that uh moves the level on to the
next uh the next phase so let's come
down uh kind of below our event handling
and let's take a look at some stuff that
we'll do to sort of handle
um what to do when a level's over so if
level is greater than zero
we'll say if
Target boxes is equal to so this is
going to be a I call it Target boxes or
Target list
why is this always so confusing for me
I'm just I'm just weak
uh Target boxes yeah okay so if Target
boxes is equal to
equal to this empty list right so not
populated at all and that's the reason
I'm putting it at the very bottom
because it will initially be empty until
we've run that draw level thing for the
first time so if Target boxes is totally
empty
and level is less than three and that's
why it's okay to check this way because
Target boxes being totally empty when it
is level three will actually be game
over command so let's say just level
plus equals one okay
and so that should do it for just
getting it to move from level one to two
and then two to three it doesn't handle
game over yet but that's okay because
that's kind of a separate Beast
um all right so let's go ahead and take
a look now if I can just clear out all
these birds really quickly and I'll try
to be accurate so you guys don't just
have to watch me play the game although
you're probably playing the game too if
you're following along bam and now we're
in level two and we should go to level
three just for the sake of testing and
because it's super fun
I'm gonna just clear these out bam and
we're in level three okay so nothing bad
is gonna happen when I clear all the
enemies here but nothing good is gonna
happen either because we have not
um we haven't taken a look at drawing
the menu or game over or uh pause or any
of the menus
um
so let's go ahead and take a look at how
to do that now let's also come in where
we have
um if level is greater than zero we're
going to draw the gun why don't we say
we'll also draw the things that will go
in the score area okay so
um in that score menu which you probably
saw on all the banners
um there's this this big block which
when I was making the static images for
the banner I didn't put anything in
there because we are going to control
what goes in there from our game
uh and we're gonna do that using the
draw score function and so you need to
just make sure that this happens in your
code after the screen.blit banners to
make sure that your stuff you're putting
in that score block gets drawn on top of
it not underneath it
all right so check shot worked great
good job everybody Pat's on the back all
around and let's go ahead and Define
what did I just call it
uh draw score brain fart all right so uh
what we're gonna put in draw score will
depend on the uh mode for a little bit
but we're gonna put a few things in
every time so we're gonna put how many
points you've gotten which will be based
on uh total number of
enemies that you've uh shot right so
font dot render and we'll make this a
formatted string so we can put some uh
text and the actual scoring in there and
we'll say points
is going to be uh points just like that
clever
and now what we'll say is true for
anti-alias which uh just Smooths the
text out and then we'll make it black
text and then we're going to put that on
screen so screen dot blit and then
points text and if you have anything
different in your game or you're
building your own version which is super
fun I recommend you just need to
probably guess and check this a little
bit to know like what the perfect pixel
position for this is
but I have found that let me just go
ahead and reformat that scoot it down a
little I found that 32660 looks really
good with where it is so if I run just
this
in about oh yeah needs to be a tuple for
your coordinates
but I am having a rough day formatting
all right so now you can see points is
down there and as I shoot these birds
our Point score updates based on uh the
levels that we created the rules and you
may say hey that text looks a little bit
small to have that full section for
itself and you're right but that's
because that's not the only thing we're
putting down there all right so let's go
ahead and copy this points text and
let's take a look at the next thing we
want to do which for me is going to be
total shots that we've taken so even in
a game mode that is not based on
accuracy I'm just going to report how
many total shots have been taken just
because that's kind of a fun stat so if
you're doing free play it's still fun to
know like how many total shots it took
you so we'll say total
shots
and then instead of points we will say
total shots just like that and we
already had that variable made and now
we're going to leave it in the same X
position but we're going to scoot it
down and we're going to scoot it down 27
pixels which might seem a little bit
arbitrary but that's actually about one
quarter of the Gap that we have and I'm
going to put a total of four pieces of
text in there so I'm going to say we are
going to show time text which is going
to be how much time you've been playing
and so for that we'll say time
elapsed and then this we're going to
need to make a new variable that we'll
call time past I guess elapsed is a
fancy word and we will just say past
when we create the variable
and then we're going to scoot down
another 87 which puts us or 27 which
puts us at 7 14. and then this last one
is going to be a little more complicated
so it's going to be based on the mode
right so if mode is zero then we want
what we'll call mode text
mode text to say
so in mode 0 it's just free play so
there's no like special game variable
that we're keeping track of
um and then we need to do some L ifs in
case we're playing an accuracy or timed
mode so if mode is one or mode is 2 then
mode text is going to change a little
and so if we're doing mode one that
means we're doing the accuracy one so
we'll say ammo remaining and then a
colon and then in here we'll put that
ammo variable that we created
and then if we're doing the mode 2 which
is going to be the timed one we'll do
timed remaining is equal to and then
we'll make a new variable called time
remaining
and uh so those for all of them it's
going to be true and that's going to be
black and we'll always put it another 27
down on the screen so that's 741 but now
obviously we have to make time passed
and time remaining variables just so it
doesn't crap out
so we'll put those down with ammo we'll
do time past and it's initially going to
be zero and time remaining
we'll also say he's going to be
initially zero because until you've
selected a game mode uh it doesn't
really matter we're not checking that
for anything right now
all right and so this needs to be mode
text instead of shots text but now we
should have a pretty full screen
um okay so we have points total shots
time elapsed and free play now total
shots and uh points will go up right now
uh time elapsed will not so it's pretty
easy to um it's pretty easy to get that
in here so let's do the time elapse just
because that's a real easy little
mechanic we're going to come down under
timer dot tick FPS and we're gonna say
if
counter is less than 60 then counter
plus equal one and then we'll say else
counter is equal to and we'll reset it
back to one so this will do one two
three four five all the way up to 60 and
then once it hits 60 we'll send it back
to one so that will be our 60fps frames
per second checker
and then we'll say if level is not equal
to actually let's put the if level above
the counter okay so if level is not
equal to zero meaning we're not in a
menu of some sort game over pause or
main menu
then we'll do our time elapsed checking
okay so if the counter is less than 60
then we want to add one to the counter
otherwise we're going to reset the
counter and then when we reset the
counter we're going to add one to time
past so time past plus equal one and
then what we're going to say is if our
mode is equal to 2 which is our timed
version of the game then we're going to
just subtract 1 from time remaining so
we don't have to worry about this yet
when we boot it up as long as we don't
put it into time remaining mode which
we're not going to do just yet okay
so this is just how we're going to track
time elapsed while we're actively
playing the game but if we're in the
menus we don't want time elapse to be
counting and so initially counter is
going to be equal to one just so it
starts right at one
um and now that's because I did less
than 60 if you wanted to do this as less
than 59 or less than or equal to 58 for
some reason if you want to complicate it
you could but I like thinking of it uh 1
through 60 just as your 60 seconds you
could think of it as 0 to 59 it's your
call but that's uh that's how we're
going to track time elapsed so there you
go now you can see without even shooting
I'm getting a basically a second every
second which looks pretty good and I can
I can miss a whole bunch and points
doesn't update but then every time I hit
a Target points updates so all the score
tracking is going really well in free
play
which brings us to the obvious question
of how do we actually change modes right
there's no way right now to play ammo uh
accuracy mode or the timed mode without
me actually changing some parameters and
we also don't start on the menu screen
so what we need to do is we need to take
a look at what do we do for drawing the
menu drawing game over and drawing pause
so let's just come into our main Loop
I'm going to collapse this if statement
here
and after we BLT stuff on the screen but
before we check the if level statements
so those three guys we're gonna add some
stuff here and we're basically going to
say if menu so we're going to need to
create a new variable called menu we're
going to say level is equal to zero
and then we're going to run this uh
we're just gonna draw everything for the
menu in a function that we'll call draw
menu I think that's the most pythonic
way of doing it and then we'll say if
game over then we are going to say again
level will be equal to zero because
that's kind of how we're going to
control if we're in a menu or not and
then this will be draw game over and
then we'll say if pause right because
that's kind of our third menu option
we'll say level equals zero and then
draw pause and we'll set this up to
where you can't really be in two of
these at the same time uh so I'm just
gonna
cut we need to make variables menu game
over and pause so let's come up here
we'll say menu is actually going to be
equal to True when we boot the game up
game over is going to be false and pause
is going to be equal to false
um
okay and so I guess I'll also make level
equal zero initially but menu being true
should do that on its own right here you
would just have a flicker of the actual
like background being drawn on if we
didn't
okay so easy enough we'll say now we
need to make draw menu draw game and
draw pause draw game over and draw pause
and so that our code doesn't throw an
error let's create all of those right
now draw menu and uh for now we'll just
put pass but we're gonna fill them out
so Define
draw
game over and I'll put pass and then I'm
gonna have to delete a w there because I
draw all right and then Define draw
pause and I'll put pass just so that it
doesn't throw an error or a hissy fit
okay and everything formatting looks
alright and now this should handle
everything we need to do while we're in
the menus so let's take a look at draw
menu that's probably the most important
one anyways
and let's go ahead and just start
thinking through what we've got to do in
here so we'll initially say game over is
false and pause is false right and to
actually be able to read uh write to
these we need them to be globals every
time I make a function and I call a
bunch of globals there's like someone in
my comments who says they wish I
wouldn't use so many globals and they
wish I would just pass everything in and
out
um I honestly don't know why people feel
so strongly about that like I'm not
making high ultra high performance data
science experiment stuff but if you know
like a good reason why this is bad
practice maybe let me know in the
comments below because I find it really
easy to call variables that I don't feel
like passing in and returning just as
globals but some people don't like it so
if you know why that is let me know
but okay the easiest thing to do is
going to be screen.blit
and then the menu image right onto the
screen because we made it a full screen
image and you're saying to yourself Pete
we didn't we don't have the menu image
and you're right so let's go grab that
uh let's come back up where we have all
of our other image loaded uh loads
coming in here and let's just go right
above that and let's do menu image
equals and then we'll have game over
image um I don't know why I'm making
this so difficult we'll do game over
image like that equals and then pause
image equals okay and so we're just
gonna kind of steal this one because we
don't know it's nice we don't have to uh
we don't have to format these ones I
made them uh 900 by 800 so they're all
ready for us okay
so this is going to be
um we don't need I anymore either this
is going to be assets and then menus and
then for main menu I called it main menu
just like that and then we'll copy this
guy
and we have main menu we have
game over and we have pause pause no
caps just like that all right so we have
our images now so when we're drawing
menu
we're going to draw the menu image onto
the screen and now let's take a look at
what else we want to do when we draw a
menu right so um kind of a lot of things
need to happen here
because on that menu screen you have the
option of doing four different things
you can choose a game mode to play so
free play or
um or ammo which is accuracy or timed
which is is giving you a certain amount
of time to get as many points as you can
or you can reset your high scores
um and so let's just sort of figure out
what to do based on the position of the
mouse so we'll say mouse pause equals
pygame.mouse.getposition which you guys
are Pros with by now
and then we'll say clicks equals
pygame.mouse dot get pressed again and
now we have a position of the mouse and
we have the uh all the clicks that are
on and now we need to figure out like
what hitboxes if you will essentially
what Collision boxes each of those
buttons should correlate to and to just
sort of show you so we have the free
play button
we have the ammo button ammo button
equals we have the timed button and then
we also have the reset button right so
we have these four buttons
um and we we want them to be invisible
rectangles because if I open up again
the main menu image real quick
you'll see it already looks like there's
buttons on the screen it already looks
like there's rectangles there so what we
want are rectangles that correlate with
that space But actually are invisible
but just so you understand like where
I'm drawing the rectangle I'll draw this
first one so pygame dot draw
Dot rect and I'll actually draw this one
on the screen and I'll just make it uh
neon green so it's kind of easy to see
and so these are we give them every
rectangle and X and Y start position and
then a width and a height and so for
like free play it just took a lot of
guess and check to get these dialed in
pretty tight but it was uh 170 524 for
starting X and Y and then 260 wide and
100 high and then just so it doesn't
block the whole button I'll make it a
width of three
and then I will just comment these ones
out so it doesn't um gum it up but I
don't know if this is going to throw an
error or not hopefully this will let you
see yeah the menu and you can hopefully
see the wireframe green there that
correlates to the free play button
so essentially we're creating a
rectangle that we're going to use for
Collision detection
um when we click on that space But we
don't want the rectangle to be visible
so rather than pygame dot draw.rect it's
pygame dot rect.rect where we just say
no we're not drawing it we're defining
it and this is what we did earlier for
the hitboxes so rather than that list of
four arguments it's two tuples so it's
like this it's a tuple and then another
Tuple and no additional arguments so
this is a fully defined rectangle
that's the one for the free play button
now we need one for the ammo button the
timed button and the reset button and
again if you're using my images or my
format from the GitHub then your buttons
will be these exact same dimensions if
you've created your own menu screens
then you just need to do some guess and
check that method that we just did to
figure out where your buttons need to be
okay so
now let's go ahead and take a look at
the ammo button and the ammo button is
going to be at the same y position but
it's further on the right and so this is
the one that says oh I want to play the
accuracy version of the game
and now the timed button is going to be
at the same X position as free play but
further down Y and then the uh reset
button is further to the right and
further down so 475 661.
and there we go now we have all four of
our buttons uh defined with rectangles
and what we want to do kind of in those
same spaces everything except the reset
button also has some text associated
with it if you think of the menu I also
show you on the main menu what your best
in each game mode was so we want to do
that in draw menu as well so let's take
a look at how to do that underneath each
underneath each button because it's kind
of associated with them
all right so we're going to draw our
best free play score uh using
screen.blit and then just in here it's
easiest to put it on one line you could
absolutely font dot render on one line
and then screen.blit on the next that's
kind of what we did with all the score
stuff
but this is pretty simple and so I'm
going to show you how you can do it all
in one line and so here uh since we
already have the text on that main menu
screen that says best time then we're
basically just going to say what the
best time was so we're going to display
here what the best free play score was
okay
and uh
um that's obviously a variable we
haven't created yet but we'll make that
in just a second I'm just going to show
you uh how to put this on the screen all
at one time and so true and then black
uh because black text on the color
buttons that I created looks pretty good
and then that is it for the font dot
render but remember we're inside a
screen.blit so then we also give it an x
and y coordinate of 340 and 580 and we
just need to go and make this variable
best free play and while we're doing
that let's go ahead and make best ammo
and best timed as well because those are
obviously the three game modes
and we'll just make them all zero
initially right because we haven't
played yet
best ammo best timed and we are going to
take a look at um
how to actually store those in a text
file which I call highscores.txt we're
going to do that once we get the
different modes working we're going to
work on reading and writing to text
files all within the game okay
so this is screened up to do best free
play and then this will be best
ammo and then down here under timed
we're gonna do best timed okay now these
all have different uh X and Y
coordinates so this first one's 345.80
this next one further uh to the right is
650 580 and then this third one I know
uh you're probably like oh it's going to
be the same x coordinate as the first
one and 340 would get you pretty close
but it actually just looks better at 350
because the text sticks out a little bit
further
um all right so that should if I uh if I
boot this up it should just give us
zeros yeah and you can see that we've
got our little high scores now if you
don't believe me that that's what they
are you can change them uh and then see
that value update but so now we're
drawing our high scores onto the menu
which is great but we also need to
figure out what to do if those buttons
are clicked okay so let's go ahead and
look at that now
let's start with the free play button so
a free play button dot Collide point and
then Collide point with the mouse
position and clicks zero and because you
have the ability to change between
um change between uh screen super
quickly like if you're on pause and you
decide to restart so it's going to take
you back to the main menu we don't want
to click buttons on multiple menus
without a lift of the button first so
we're going to create another variable
in just a second called clicked to track
whether or not you've already clicked on
the
um on a button and if you have clicked
on a button and then it takes you to
another menu we're not going to reset
clicked until we see you've lifted the
mouse key so this is just a way to
prevent unwanted double clicking
all right well and everything we want to
do when you click free play is we want
to say mode equals one and then level
equals one and so that'll launch us into
the game and then we'll set menu equal
to false that's got to be on new level a
new line mode level menu equal to false
and then we want to basically say time
past equals zero because if you just
finished the game and you went back to
the main menu you want to reset all of
your game variables so total shots also
equals zero and then points also equals
zero so basically you're starting a new
game okay and you can see these are all
gray because they're not yet Global
variables so we're going to go ahead and
call them all in our globals line
and again I find this really easy I
don't know if it's slower or less
pythonic I don't actually know
um I do know some people don't like that
I do this so if you know a better way of
doing it feel free to do it I know that
you can pass these in as parameters and
then return them I don't know that that
substantially makes a difference for
this project
so uh okay total shots and then points
just like that and now we can actually
write to all of those things
already so that's going to handle what
to do if we click on the free play
button and the other four buttons lucky
for us are fairly similar okay
so let's just copy it twice and let's
take a look at what to do first for ammo
we're going to kind of handle the reset
button on its own because it's a little
different
um okay so then we will say if the ammo
button is clicked well then mode is one
level is one menu is still going to be
equal to false because we want to exit
the menu and then now we need to reset
we need to give ammo a value so we need
to come up to our globals and say ammo
as well so that we're able to write to
that
and then ammo is equal to 81 and the
reason I picked 81 is because that's how
many targets I have total in my game you
can total these up if you don't believe
me but I basically wanted to say if
you're playing the accuracy game mode
the best possible score you can get is
hitting every single Target so you can
spend forever making sure your mouse is
lined up and chasing those targets down
and you can basically pursue Perfection
so the ammo mode it is possible to get a
perfect score if you manage to hit every
single Target with every single click
that is how I got 81. all right so total
shots time passed and points will all
still be zero and uh now let's take a
look at what to do
in the timed mode so we don't care here
about
um mode will be equal to we don't care
about Ammo in here but what we do care
about is now time remaining right so
time remaining and we want to set it
equal to something where it's extremely
difficult to clear the entire game I
played this quite a few times and I
found 30 seconds like almost impossible
to hit so I am going with 30 seconds
um but if you find that to be too easy
feel free to do a smaller one so
time well let's just make a second row
for uh globals because I don't want to
spill over I don't want to have
something that I need to use scroll bars
to view so all right time remaining and
that's it for these buttons let's go
ahead and create the variable clicked
initially so we'll say clicked equals
false and we'll take a look at how to
track that once we are out of this
little Loop okay so that's free play
ammo and timed now let's go ahead and
say well what about the reset button so
if reset button dot Collide point with
the mouse position then that means we've
just said we want to get rid of all our
high scores it's not accurate or that
wasn't me or that was my friend playing
or I just want to reset it like I got
perfect once but uh you know I want to
keep chasing that Dragon well we're
going to set all of our bests back to
zero so best free plays equals zero best
ammos equals zero and then best time is
equal to zero and then we actually
actually are going to want to create
another write values command which is
going to be true so we're going to
actually say I want to reset my scores
so go and overwrite go and overwrite
whatever's in your text file okay so now
let's import the bests as well because
we're overriding them in here
best free play ammo and timed and uh
alrighty so that should do it we also
want to bring in right values even
though we haven't created it yet we are
about to
all right so we'll say initially write
values is false and this should be
really cool we obviously aren't doing
anything with that clicked variable yet
but we set equal to false so we're going
to boot up we're going to be on the menu
and if I do free play
okay it says right at the bottom free
play and the nice thing about free play
is you have infinite ammo and infinite
time so your score will always be all
the way up like you'll always finish a
free play round by shooting every Target
every enemy
um but the scoring in free play is based
on how long it takes you so basically
you're going to be getting progressively
higher scores as you manage to do free
play faster and faster and then the
other two
because it's very difficult to get all
of the enemies the other two scores are
based on your time so actually your free
play score will keep getting better as
you get a faster and lower time
okay I can't get that one that's okay
um let's boot that up and see if it does
timed for us so countdown all right and
now it says time remaining and you can
see the time is ticking and if you don't
believe me that 30 seconds is really
hard go ahead and try to beat it in 30
seconds maybe you're just an absolute
computer whiz and you can't miss and you
manage to beat the whole thing in 30
seconds but I usually find myself about
halfway through the UFO level and if I
try to get the purple UFOs on timed it's
it's like legitimately impossible I just
the only way I can even get close is if
I just don't worry about the purples and
I do like red green and blues then
sometimes with 30 seconds like I get all
of them except purple but I don't think
I've eaten
um beating it in 30 yet and you can see
see the time remaining is just counting
negative because we haven't created game
over conditions yet
all right so let's go ahead and take a
look at the clicked thing that I was
talking about a little bit before and
then I will also explain as we get to
the pause in game over menus like why
that's so important
but uh to handle the clicking the way
I'm kind of thinking of it we need a new
um if event.type command which is going
to be if event DOT type is equal to
pygame Dot
Mouse button up this time so that means
we've lifted the key and event oop
get pretty bad at spelling as again hour
two of the tutorials and event dot
button is equal to one again
and clicked right so that means we've
detected a click is true somewhere then
we're just going to say okay well you've
lifted up on the key so clicked is now
equal to false and we don't need to
actually turn clicked to True inside of
the menu we just need to do that for
pause in game over which we'll talk
about in just a second but the reason
for that is every button in the main
menu is uh pretty harmless it takes you
into the game so uh just to boot this up
and illustrate what I mean if you were
to click any of these buttons it's going
to take you into the game or this is
just going to reset high scores so
you don't actually need to uh to do it
in the menu button but we will just for
good practice
um if you if you saw there what happened
is I booted this up and then I clicked
on reset high scores so that's really so
I clicked right here but if I drag the
mouse now to accuracy it starts the game
up with our like set number of shots
that we have to play the game
um and so that kind of sucks because we
want like the Click to only work on the
button that we clicked so there's one
more thing we need to do and draw menu
and I promise we're done with this
behemoth
we need to also have the clicked value
in here and we need to save any of these
buttons get clicked so here then we also
need to say okay well clicked is equal
to true so this is basically saying
you're not allowed to do anything else
with the mouse button until you release
it so you can't just drag the button
around that's kind of how we handled the
uh that's kind of how we handled the
like not having a laser beam when you
shoot enemies right so it's just as
important here
and now let's take a look at game over
and pause so first let's take a look at
what to do if you enter pause and to do
that it's really easy it's just kind of
an add-on to the mouse tracking that we
already did for Mouse button down right
so
uh here we've checked to see if the
mouse position is in a certain spot
when we click and it's the left key well
it's the same thing for
pause and the reset buttons right so if
you hit restart when you're let me pull
up a banner again
if you hit restart we're going to let
you go back to the menu and choose what
mode uh you want to play so we're gonna
say uh first let's take a look at
um
pause yeah pause is better first because
it's higher so we'll say now 670 and
less than 860. so again I have kind of
figured out where the start and stop of
those buttons are and I decided to just
do it this way rather than create
additional like Collision boxes so
essentially the pause button is between
670 and 860 in the X Direction and 660
and 715 in the y direction and I got
those by guess and check so I'm trying
to save you a little time but you could
create another rectangle just like we
did with the menu buttons and you could
figure out where pause is then
but so if we enter pause what I'm going
to do is I'm going to store whatever
level we're on in a variable called
resume level because when we enter all
of the pause the menu
um the game over when we do all of that
stuff remember that we set level equal
to zero but if you pause and then you
decide to resume obviously we want to
put you back to whatever level you were
at and so to do that we're going to
store it in this variable we'll call
resume level
and then we're going to set just this
value pause equal to true and since
we're here let's take a look at what to
do with the restart button as well we're
basically just going to say now it's
still 670 to 860. it's just right below
it so it's 7 15 all the way down to 760.
now for the uh restart and all we're
gonna do if that's the case is we're
going to set menu equal to true and we
don't need to track resume level because
you're avoiding your you're avoiding
your right to uh
um
you're avoiding your right to
what's the word I'm trying to say
restart your your you're not allowed to
resume you're saying you want to reboot
the whole thing uh okay and then in here
we'll say both of these will also set
clicked equal to true so your mouse
can't just go Hog Wild all right and so
uh let's go ahead and take a look at how
to draw pause now right because we say
if pause then we want to draw a pause
it's quite a bit simpler than um it's
quite a bit simpler than draw menu which
you might expect because there's only
two things you can really do in it so
first thing we'll do is screen dot blit
and we'll let the pause image this time
which is a different menu that we
created
and we'll still put it at zero zero
because I nicely made all of the menus
900 by 800.
and we're still going to want that Mouse
pause and we're still going to want that
clicks uh because we're still checking
to see if buttons are collided and now
uh the button positions are the same as
the bottom two buttons so I'm going to
grab our reset button and our timed
button I'm going to grab those and I'm
going to copy them we're going to change
them and we don't need these screen dot
BLT texts anymore but the one that's 170
to 661 on our pause menu is actually the
button for resume so if we look at that
the lower left button versus the main
menu the buttons are in exactly the same
spot which is super nice we can use the
same rectangles
but that means that this is not the
timed button this is the resume button
but the dimensions are the same and then
this is sort of the reset button but
it's actually the menu button to be
honest
um and so let's take a look at what to
do if the resume button is dot Collide
point with mouse pause just like when we
checked them in the menu and clicks zero
so the left Mouse is clicked and not
clicked which means we've lifted the
mouse since the last time we selected
something
well then we just want the level to be
equal to resume level so that temporary
thing we stored in and then we want to
set pause equal to false and it's really
nice that's all we have to do so to be
able to overwrite the level we obviously
need Global level and we obviously need
Global pause uh pause I don't know why I
said that so weird okay now let's look
at what to do if the menu button is
clicked because that's obviously a bit
more complicated because we're now
saying uh we went to pause we thought
maybe we'd want to resume but we
actually decided we didn't we just want
to scrap this and choose a new game mode
and if that's the case then we check if
it's collided with the mouse and it was
the left click not the scroll wheel not
the right click and not clicked already
so this is what we intended to do with
this click well we're going to make sure
that level stays zero this is a little
redundant because
um
because level should already be zero but
it's never a bad idea to cover your butt
when you reset things all right so pause
is going to be false we're going to set
menu equal to true and then we're going
to go in here and we're just going to
say all right well I'm wiping all of the
game conditions that you have now so
total shots points time past
and time remaining and we're just going
to reset all of these to
um to uh
their original states and we're also
going to set clicked equal to true we're
going to do that for both buttons so
when we enter a new menu we can't mess
with it okay and so obviously we need
these as globals we need menu we need
points we need total shots we need time
passed
time remaining I wonder if the reason
people don't like this is just because
it's kind of it looks silly and it's
time consuming or if it's actually an
efficiency issue
um
okay so uh basically we're saying if
we're on the pause menu and we click the
no go back to the main menu menu then
you're voiding your ability to resume
however you were playing but if you hit
the resume button gonna go right back
into the game like nothing happened so
uh let's actually test this
functionality out I think that should be
everything we need to get it working so
let's play free play real quick shoot
like four birds and you'll see time
elapsed is four when I hit pause I'm
gonna give it like a few seconds so it
should definitely be increasing from
four if our counter wasn't paused and
you see it still says time elapsed as
well five as soon as I load it back in
but our counter resumed and then my
shots started going back up based on
just uh
just shooting more targets and my points
stayed the same but now if I hit pause
and I go to main menu
and then I go back to free play
oh that's interesting so let's figure
out what we did wrong what I did wrong
I'm not blaming you guys for anything
you guys are great okay I think I I see
what's going on uh it's funny that I
didn't catch it but basically when it
wasn't that it was retaining level two
as a score it was keeping level one but
we never re-initialize the coordinates
for the game so when we had the uh all
of our initial coordinates that we kind
of Define outside of the main game Loop
right down here we never reinitialize
these coordinates anywhere so basically
uh it was loading in at level zero but
we never redefined the coordinates so
it's on empty list and then it moved on
it figured like okay well
um you know then level one is done so
I'm going to level two and so what we
need to do for that is we just basically
need to initialize the coordinates
anytime we start start a new version of
the game okay and I think the easiest
way to do this is to say basically
if level equals one
if level equals one and not a variable
we'll call new chords then we want to
initialize all of the coordinates just
like that and so we'll make this
variable new chords
new
coords equals and we'll set it equal to
false right when the game boots up and
then we will we can get rid of these now
I guess we should be able to
and then we'll say
if where did I put that if level is
equal to one and not new chords then we
want to initialize these coordinates but
then we also at the end want to set
new coords equal to
false or true what I say it was in the
beginning yeah and not it's true okay
and so this is kind of an easy way to
get yeah yeah now uh what we'll do is
we'll say
when we're in draw menu
if any of these buttons new chords if
any of these buttons get pressed these
free play ammo or timed then we'll say
new coords equals false so this means we
need new coordinates maybe that was
backwards maybe I should have said if
new chords are being called for but this
should do the trick
so now anytime we're in that menu and we
choose a game mode one chords is not
defined dang it maybe the issue is just
that these should be initialized in the
very beginning
foreign
well that's sure certainly didn't give
me
new coordinates it sent me right to
level three okay I'm thinking let's try
to make uh new chords when new chords is
true we want to re-initialize these
values so we'll say
draw menu draw pause
down here
and if level is one and we're calling
for new chords
then we're gonna go through do this
whole list we aren't going to yeah we we
want it like that and then in our draw
menu if any of these buttons get pressed
we want to set new coordinates equal to
true so it's time for you to go through
and get a new set of coordinates
not that one that one
all right all right so I think this code
would be working pretty sweet if I
didn't have this if level equals one in
here and we really don't need the if
level equals one I think the issue is
when you click on a button in menu
you're inside this line of code and so
then you click on it and then we come
right down here to where it's checking
the levels and it sees that there's no
enemies in the list so it goes straight
to three and that looks like it's over
so what we want to do is say anytime it
says we need new coordinates immediately
give me new coordinates that should work
pretty well
so let's go ahead Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam
pause pause and let's resume and we
still have the same birds and let's see
if I can get to the second level
okay and now I'm on the second level
I'll shoot a few blue plates let's pause
it now let's go to the main menu let's
hit free play again
okay well this is progress because it
gives us all the the blue plates back
there's no shot plates but it keeps us
on level two which is very interesting
okay there's been a lot of
troubleshooting here and I promise I'm
gonna edit out the parts where I just
quietly am sitting and thinking to
myself but I think the last thing we
need to do is just when we enter the
menu we need to set new chords equal to
True right there rather than waiting so
basically I think we are writing new
coordinates too late so let's try
setting new chords equal to True every
time we go to the main menu right so
that would be here
as well
and so this should essentially give us a
full new uh list and then that's good
because every time uh we go to Bam Bam
and then bam yeah okay so this is gonna
set level equal to one when we enter and
because the menu is down here uh before
the new cords this just means that we
need the new coordinates to be generated
before we actually click the button on
the menu so the menu button is going to
be too late for us to do anything about
it so now if in free play if I can go
ahead and clear this first level
all right now I'm in level two I swear
if I restart and I do free play again
it'll send us back to one okay now if I
get to two and I do pause and then main
menu it should also send us back to
level one
pause main menu free play level one okay
so I apologize for the troubleshooting I
will hopefully edit out the most painful
Parts but I think it's useful to see
that even when it's a project where you
have a plan and you have a preparation
plan you can be a little confused by
what's going on and it just didn't make
sense to me but now I see what was
happening is we were saying level equal
to one and calling new coords at the
same time but we create the new
coordinates at the very top of every
Loop and so we saw the button was
clicked around here and then we came
down here and saw that the target boxes
were completely empty and so then we
moved the level up one and then the next
Loop happened and that's why it was
automatically kicking us to level two I
hope that made sense I apologize for the
delay but let's keep going now so we've
got a pretty cool system
for pause the menus are working pretty
well so I think it's time that we check
out uh game over conditions and I'm sure
this will go just as smoothly as
everything else so far
but essentially game over conditions are
just going to be underneath this if
level is greater than zero because
there's no point checking if game over
under any other circumstances and now
there's kind of three ways to have a
game over so if game if level is equal
to three and the target boxes is equal
to
these three four empty boxes right so if
this happens then it's game over but
there's other ways it could happen too
or mode equals one right which is the
accuracy and ammo is equal to zero right
so that means we've run out of bullets
because then the game's over as well
or
mode is equal to two and time remaining
has gone down to zero okay so let me
enter so that we're on
uh a new rung time zero and let's put a
new line character in there so that
we're able to do it this way okay so
these are the three different things
that could actually cause game over
we've actually cleared the entire board
that could happen in any game mode but
especially free play
or we've run out of ammo in the accuracy
mode or uh we have run out of time in
the timed mode and now
okay so what do we do in one of these
three game over conditions happens
um well we want to set new chords equal
to true so right off the bat we're
saying we're gonna enter game over and
so the menu is going to uh basically pop
up first it'll say game over and give
you the option to play again or just
exit the program but in either case we
want to get cooking on those new chords
in the background and then let's take a
look at what to actually do because
obviously
um the variable game over is going to be
equal to True that'll be something that
we use for our draw game over
and then we're going to set level equal
to zero but we don't actually need this
here because that's already in the draw
game over conditions
so what we want to do is we want to
track what was the actual score there
that we were tracking and put that into
our
um kind of like our Logic for was this a
high enough score that we should
overwrite our best score
all right so now let's go ahead and just
take a look at how to do that so we'll
say if mode was equal to zero that means
we were doing free play and that will
mean if our time passed is less than our
best free play score ever or our best
free play was equal to zero because the
only way best free play score is zero is
if you haven't beaten the game before so
in any case this is your best score
and then we're going to set our best
free play equal to time past
and that variable right values is going
to be equal to true because we're going
to say we not only want to overwrite it
in our local Python program but we want
to overwrite it in the text file as well
all right so then the next check is not
if mode is zero it's going to be if mode
is one all right and so if mode is one
then what we want to do is say if points
is greater than our best ammo score
then best ammo is going to be equal to
points and then we also want to write
values and so this is we we only want to
update one best score at a time right
you can't beat your best free play score
and your best time score at the same
time uh so this is kind of how we're
gonna do that we handle it situation by
situation
so then for mode 2 which is timed if
points again is better than your best
time score
then your best time score gets set equal
to however many points you got and then
we are still going to write values
equals true
I missed an equals true here you guys
caught it though good job
all right and then game over equals true
and that should take care of it so let
me reformat this file a little bit
reformat the file there we go and then
that'll set game over equal to true and
then we'll handle everything to do for
the game over uh stuff kind of inside
the draw game over just like we have
with pause and menu
and I know that was a little chaotic but
that's just how I roll so let's go ahead
and keep draw pause open because draw
game over will have a few similarities
all right so first thing we'll do is
we'll say if mode is equal to zero then
the display score because we want to
tell them what their score is will be
equal to however much time was passed
right because if the game is over and
the mode was Zero that means you were
playing free play
so your score is however much time was
passed and then we will say else meaning
it was mode one or two then the display
score is equal to however many points
you scored all right so those are
basically the two scenarios and so
screen dot blit
first thing we want to put on the screen
is game over image obviously just like
the pause and menus
and again it's
the right size so we just put it at zero
zero we don't need to scale it
and we're going to get the mouse
position in clicks which I will just
steal from pause because I'm a sneaky
thief and then uh okay now Mouse pause
and clicks and then we are going to
define the exit button and the menu
button and we are going to steal you
guessed it the resume button and the
menu button okay so the resume button is
uh gonna be the new exit button but the
position is already correct because I
made both of my menus that have two
buttons in the same spot
and menu is in the right spot as well so
now what we want to do is screen dot
blit our display score
onto the screen but instead of font dot
render so right we have the one font
defined up top I actually want to make a
new bigger font here it is I want to
make a bigger font because this is kind
of the only place where your score is
displayed right after you like win and
so it's kind of nice to see that in a
little more clarity so we'll Define
another font that I'll call Big Font
pygame.font.font and then assets forward
slash font forward slash my font so it's
going to be the same font file but I
want this to be much larger so I'll make
it 60 instead of 32.
and now we'll come back down into draw
game over screen dot split and then
display score
um is what we are going to BLT onto the
screen but we haven't rendered it yet so
it's screen.blit and then font dot
render and again it's not font.render
this one is going to be Big Font dot
render so
Big Font dot render I like to be
descriptive in my names and then this
one we will just make it uh another F
string and this will be the display
score so whatever it is whether it's
points if you played mode one or two or
if it's just time passed if you played
free play we'll display that there
and then true and then we'll make it
black and then uh the position to put
this in is 650 570 that's just a good
that's a good spot to put this text 650.
570. okey dokey and now we just need to
check what to do if these buttons are
clicked right so if menu button dot
Collide point with the mouse pause and
you should be familiar with all these
conditions by now and it was the left
click and we have not already clicked
something first we'll set clicked equal
to true so it doesn't automatically take
us to the main menu and then uh
and then immediately click whatever
button is underneath that spot so we
need Global clicked and we're going to
have a few globals again buckle up
all right but level is going to stay
equal to zero it should have been
already but it does not hurt to be
cautious and then pause is going to be
equal to false and then game over is
going to be equal to false and this is
just a way of checking that we're
essentially getting a reset out of this
when we go to the menu so menu equals
true
um so we are going to get Global clicked
level pause
game over
menu and let's see what else menu uh and
then we want points to be equal to zero
total shots to be equal to zero time
past equal to zero time remaining equal
to zero right
so let's go ahead and say menu is coming
in points is coming in total shots is
coming in
time passed time remaining you're like
Pete this is so similar to clicking the
menu button from pause why didn't you
click that why don't you copy that I
don't know it's a good point that would
have been way better
uh okay and now let's say if exit button
this one's actually the easiest uh this
one's the easiest by far so if exit
button dot Collide point with the mouse
position
and it was the left click and I haven't
already clicked we don't even need to do
anything else complicated we're just
going to call
the run right here and we're going to
set it equal to false okay so we're just
basically saying if I hit exit when I'm
on game over that means I'm done done
and I'm just want to close the
application so that's a quick and easy
way to do that and now game over should
work uh it's a big should Pete but I'm
gonna stake my reputation on it my
reputation is not worth anything anyways
so actually to make this uh game over
testing a little bit easier I'm going to
start us on level three uh just because
so uh that way I can test game over
without having to make you guys watch me
play three levels so let's go for it
uh oh right it gets immediately
overwritten
should have been okay so we get the
amount of time that elapsed which for
free play seems pretty good now if we go
to main menu you can actually see the
free play best score uh now says 37
which is great if I hit reset high
scores you'll see it goes to zero which
is also good that's what we want and if
I played through the accuracy modes um
let's see if I can just quickly burn
through all my shots so
I'll probably hopefully crop some of me
clicking out but it's not that it's not
taking that long
um but you can see I've got I've used up
all my bullets okay score is 200
accuracy score took countdown I'm not
going to make you guys wait 30 seconds
but we verified that the pause works the
free play works the reset high scores
works
so the next thing we want to do is we
want to take a look at actually storing
those values in an external text file so
that when we close this out but we come
back and we play it the next day or we
play it in a month or a year our high
scores will all be stored and reading
and writing from a text file is actually
super simple so let's go ahead and take
a look at how to do that now first thing
you want to do is you want to make sure
inside of your game structure you have a
text file I called mine highscores.txt
in the same location as your main.pi
file
and you can see mine actually has my
best scores from uh when I was playing
around this before
okay and so it goes
free play ammo timed and it's just each
row
is a different
um is a different uh
game mode high score
okay so for Iron Range one through four
right underneath this spot where we
loaded in all of the images we're gonna
do a couple lines of really simple code
it's just file equals open and then the
file you want to read from and for us
it's highscores.txt I'm not sure why
I've got crap jumping all over my screen
maybe because I typed it in wrong all
right but you just say what file you
want to open and then an r or a W for
read or write and now when we first boot
the game up we want to read because we
want to get the previous high scores
from there so we do read underscore file
which is where we're going to store what
we actually read out of it in file dot
read lines just like that and then it's
going to give us a list essentially of
strings separated by like new line
characters so then we just do file Dot
close file.close is to protect the data
basically you don't want an open file
the whole time your program is running
and now what we're going to do is we're
going to say best free play is equal to
the integer equivalent of what's in read
file zero so line zero of the thing that
we just read
and then we're going to say best ammo is
the next one and then best
what is this best timed is the next ones
and so that's lines one two uh zero one
and two and that's all we need to do to
read the high scores in when we
initially boot this thing up and only
slightly more complicated than that is
what to do when we want to write a new
high score so if you remember we've been
using uh write values all over the place
when it's time to write a new high score
that's this variable write values equals
true let's just come down at the very
bottom here and say if write values that
means that for some reason we have a new
time that we want to a new score that we
want to write it's the same file.open
command
and you want to point it to the same uh
the same file but now instead of an R
it's a W for right okay and then we do
file dot right this time and uh now this
is important you're overwriting the
stuff in there so you want to give it
everything every time so even if it's
only best free play or best ammo or best
time that got updated we we need to give
it all three of these every time
so we do a format string we start with
best free play and then we use the
backslash n new line character and then
we do best ammo and then we say new line
and then new line and then we give it
best timed and that order is important
because that's the order it'll be
getting red back in in all right and
then we do
file indentations wrong file Dot close
just like this and then we want to set
write values equal to false so we only
do that once we're not just constantly
uh overwriting it while it runs okay so
now you'll see I have 39 16 30 and 1570
in my high scores.txt file if I boot
this up we should yeah we get 39 16 30
and 1570 which is great now the test of
if our right is working is if I hit
reset high scores
these all go to zero but if I close this
bad boy and now I open high scores.txt
you'll see I get zero zero zero now the
next time that I boot this up
I get all zeros and what's really cool
is as you play through this and you beat
each game mode it's gonna store that
high score for you in that location okay
so I think the time has come to add
sound and I always do this at the very
end because sound is super fun but it
does make the tutorial a little bit
harder because I'm competing with sounds
from the computer as I install as I we
put sound in then I have to like talk
over it
so let's go ahead and start the tool
that we need to make sounds work in our
PI game game and we'll do pygame.mixer
dot init and just like that that's all
we have to give it and then
pygame.mixer.music.load just like that
and then we do assets forward slash
sounds and then the uh song that I got
for this one was just a royalty-free
song from YouTube and uh I stored it in
Assets in sounds and then called it a BG
music Okay so
that's where we have the sound stored
and now let's say uh the three different
targets when you shoot them they all
make different sounds which is kind of
fun so plate sound is going to be equal
to
pygame.mixer.capital S sound and then in
here we just point it in the right
direction so assets sounds and then
forward slash and this one's broken
plates dot wav and then we have uh to do
something extra or it'll be really loud
is plate underscore sound dot set volume
and I'm just going to give it a a 20 or
0.2 command to set the plate so that's
kind of relative to your computer volume
and your music volume but you don't want
these like plates and these birds and
these flying saucers to be super duper
loud uh you well you can play around
this as much as you want but I didn't
want to be super loud so I uh the sound
I used for the bird because I didn't
want you to like I didn't want to sound
like you're shooting actual Birds I got
one called drill gear which you'll hear
it still sounds pretty good
and then laser sound is actually pretty
sweet and all the sounds came from
YouTube's royalty-free Library so we're
not infringing on everything anything
and the laser is actually a little bit
quieter so 0.3 works better than 0.2 for
that one and it's called laser gun dot
wave okay and so then what we'll do is
we'll say pygame dot mixer dot music dot
play and we'll just start the music
right here and then what we'll do as
well I think is in draw menu we'll say
when you click uh
now let's say when you enter the menu
from anywhere so there's three places
you could enter the menu right you could
enter it from the main screen when you
press reset
so here when you hit the reset button
you go into the menu we'll start the
music then and then if game over is true
so in here do do regardless of what mode
you're in you're going to the main menu
so we'll say music is true and then if
in draw pause you click the menu button
then we'll do that as well okay so
that's it now the music will restart
anytime you enter the menu which is cool
and now we're gonna go into uh check
shot which is where we check to see if
the target has been shot and now we're
gonna check and see what the level is to
determine what player sound we should
make so
if level is one then we want the bird
sound to play bird sound dot play and
then we'll say l if level is equal to
two then we want the plate sound to play
dot play and then L if level equals
three or you could just do else then we
want laser sound to play okay so ideally
if we got everything right and I know I
keep saying that and it is kind of
tricky when we boot this up now we'll be
on the menu screen and uh let me set a
beginner level back to zero even though
I think the game does that for us yeah
so menu should be true and this music
should play and I think it's really
sweet music
um but obviously I am competing with
background sound now so let's just play
a little
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so maybe those sound effects are a
little bit too quiet compared with how
loud the music is so your options are
you could either set the music volume
down a little bit or you could bring
those sound effect sounds back up a
little bit alright
so uh only thing I'd say that you
probably are going to want to do is
0.2.2 and 0.3 was a little bit quiet so
maybe play around with the balancing for
a little bit make them a little bit
louder but uh holy cow guys that was a
huge project we have three totally
awesome levels you could easily expand
that and add levels to it if you wanted
to we have sound effects we have music
we have scoring we have menus that are
uh interactive and you can pause the
game and resume the game we have all
this different functionality this is a
really complete game and you guys should
be super stoked that we just finished
the whole project it was obviously a ton
of code I apologize for the sections we
got a little bogged down in
troubleshooting but that's real
programming so if you have any questions
or you want to make any modifications to
the GitHub and create your own version
I'd be super stoked to see those if you
found this useful if you found this fun
and you wanted to see tons more great
content consider checking out the
channel subscribe to the channel leave a
like on the video it helps me a ton I
hope you guys really really like the
game as always let me know in the
comments if there's any questions at all
as always good luck with your code and
thanks for watching thanks bye